powerful winter storm hitting the west
coast wears hundreds of people from
their homes across a wide area of
Southern California a wall of mud
triggered by heavy rain damaged houses
in Encino
that's northwest of Los Angeles the
downpour sent rivers of mud rock and
debris down roads near Malibu last night
the storm delivered more than two feet
of snow to the Sierra Nevada cars and
trucks spun off Interstate 80 which is
closed still closed in some areas this
morning and residents are bracing for
even more severe weather they've got two
more days of heavy rain and blizzard
conditions that are expected in
California before that storm takes aim
at the East Coast to this weekend Lonnie
Quinn chief weather caster of our New
York station WCBS is tracking the storms
path Lonnie good morning this is an
interesting one yeah it sure is and you
know you talk about the situation in
California I think the worst has yet to
come it's gonna get really rough out
there over the next couple of days look
at this from the National Weather
Service they're saying three to five
inches is the operative number for
California that's three to five inches
of rain at the coast more mudslides
possible three to five feet of snow in
the Sierra now for the East Coast City
this is gonna start as snow it's gonna
change over to rain so can go back to
snow the question this is the big
question how long will each one of those
stages last and then brutally cold air
we know this for sure a brutally cold
air comes in right after or as it's
actually transitioning out of the areas
so I mean it could be dropping 30
degrees in 12 to 18 hours how much snow
we're picking up will you take a look at
how this whole thing is going to
progress this blue color going through
Indianapolis over towards Columbus is
about six inches of snow
we also think it'll be about six inches
of snow for some of the East Coast
cities like New York up to Boston and I
realized the models have been wavering
they've been going back and forth but
they've been holding true with the
biggest numbers being inland north and
west places like the Mohawk Mountains in
in New York all the through northern New
England could see two feet of snow and
then this pink color shows you the zero
degree readings that we'll be dropping
in on top of whatever is either snow or
rain it's gonna freeze really quickly
come late Sunday night into early Monday
morning tough travel out there I guess
the only you can say is folks aren't
commuting necessarily because it is a
holiday come Monday morning this is a
real tough and dangerous storm John
let's go over to you
alright Lonnie thank you when you say
things like brew
cold it's not good and wait you see this
is gonna be this is gonna wake everybody
up on the East Coast
all right well head to the grocery store
and start stocking up thanks Lonnie